feels good to say this monday
p-f-t-o-t it has been a while since
we've done a pft ot it's been a while
since we've done pft live this is where
we talk about the things we either
didn't get to or we'd like to talk about
in more detail chris sims mike florio
here we talked about the patrick mahomes
contract that was done two weeks ago
we didn't talk about the dak prescott
deal that wasn't done before the window
closed on long-term deals for franchise
tag players on wednesday of last week
chris how surprised were you one to ten
that they didn't work out a long term
deal oh i mean uh i i mean
like if one was no surprise at all it
was a one i didn't expect it to happen i
mean just the way it kind of unfolded i
think throughout the off-season
it seemed like there was a line drawn in
the sand and neither side was going to
cross it
and i was not shocked at all and i think
mike to that adds to that conversation
once i saw mahomes contract i felt like
that was just gonna make the dallas
cowboys dig their heels in even deeper
and go okay look he just accepted this
and dak prescott we think you're awesome
but you're certainly not that guy over
there number 15 in red and white
and you know you're asking for the same
or very similar or more in the first
four years and i once i saw that i just
knew there was no way dak prescott was
getting anything long-term
let me ask you this yeah
if the cowboys were to take
the patrick mahomes contract scratch out
chiefs put in cowboys scratch out my
homes put in dak
one do you think the cowboys would do it
and two do you think dak would accept it
oh i i don't know as it stands right now
i don't think dak would accept it no
um and
uh i do think the cowboys would do it
yes i think the cowboys would be like
sure yeah hey let's do this right okay
you want to do this sounds good to us
no i think where it could be tempting
for a guy like dak prescott
you know is the fact that he hasn't made
big money yet or anything like that but
the mahomes contract
because of the lack of the signing bonus
or anything it doesn't really give
anything you know for a guy like dak
prescott who hasn't any made any money
yet to go oh okay here we go here's my
first chunk of change i got this this is
good and we go from there so uh i
certainly think that dak wouldn't accept
it and i think the cowboys would love to
give him that contract i guarantee you
he wouldn't have taken it when you look
out what he's going to make this year
31.4 million under the franchise tag
mahomes is making like 10 between 10 and
11 million right this year now we talked
earlier about guaranteed money possibly
being at risk as part of the potential
cancellation of the season and dak
wouldn't get his money but i i i look
it's a better deal for him to go year to
year under the tag and that's ultimately
what the analysis was chris this is
something we talked about over and over
again what were the cowboys going to
offer dak prescott to get him to give up
the bird in the hand 31.4 million this
year 37.68 million next year and then
the kirk cousins conundrum for 2022. do
they transition tag him do they
franchise tag him do they let him walk
away after he's made 69.08 million for
two years of football i mean ultimately
it's a simple analysis for him he
treated last year like a contract year
and got paid 2 million this year he
treats it like a contract year and he's
going to get paid 31.4 million and they
didn't offer him enough to get him to
say i'll trade in what i have and take
what you're offering me instead no they
did not and you know again there's the
risk i'm hey i'm sitting here as a
living proof that there's a risk when
you don't you know take your money
sometimes you might you might not get
all the money that you you could have
possibly had
but at the same time dak prescott you've
mentioned this many times before we know
this he's never been injured and
i think it's a less of a gamble in 2020
for a quarterback to do these type of
things than ever before because we know
the rules to protect the quarterbacks
you know we just don't see as many
franchise quarterbacks lost for the year
as we used to in the 80s and 90s and
early 2000s so i think because of that
deck prescott and his camp probably feel
a little bit more comfortable uh rolling
the dice on this you know scenario maybe
than you would 10 20 years ago
yeah and look you can go out and buy
insurance to protect yourself against
the catastrophic injury uh the key is
the cash in hand he's got the
endorsement money he's got the guarantee
and one argument that i heard last week
about dak prescott
there's no guarantee that the cowboys
would tag him again next year and so if
the cowboys don't tag him next year at
37.68 million no one else is going to
pay him 37.68 million so he should just
do the best deal he can long term with
the cowboys now do you think they'll tag
him next year or what do you think it
would take for them not to tag him next
year and pay him 37.68 well yeah i think
it would
first off if they weren't it would take
one maybe a disaster of a year right to
where you go okay whoa the cowboys were
four and 12 and he didn't play whoa he
played bad they might then just go you
know what and and if they were a bad
record and had a top 10 pick they might
just go hey the hell with it we're not
going to pay you 37 million or anything
like that we might just draft a
quarterback i don't see that happening
one because i think dak prescott is one
of the 10 best quarterbacks in football
right now two i think
dallas cowboys got a lot of talent
around him to you know accentuate his
talents and make him look maybe even
better especially the fact that he gets
cd lamb in the top 20 to go along with a
pretty dangerous core of wide receivers
already so i i i just don't see that
happening but to me that would be the
circumstance maybe
uh that that you would see dallas say
forget about it but i think anything
like
borderline playoffs dak prescott has
anything close to what he did this year
where he's top of football in a lot of
statistical areas i think dallas is
either gonna yeah it's gonna be the
franchise tag once again or maybe
they'll pony up the money for a
long-term contract
here was my response when someone told
me last week the cowboys wouldn't tag
him next year it was very simple they
chose the highest possible level this
year they didn't have to go exclusive
with 31.4 they could have saved 4
million or so with non-exclusive and put
him out there if somebody wants to sign
him to an offer sheet that the cowboys
won't match take the two first round
draft picks and move on they went with
the cadillac version of the franchise
tag that tells me they want him see the
problem is
they've delayed and they've delayed and
they've delayed paying him what they
should pay him and it keeps getting more
and more expensive so next year if they
do tag him chris the starting point is
37.68 on a long-term deal and then when
you get into 2022 you've got 45 million
plus under the transition tag 54 million
plus under the franchise tag if they tag
him a third time or he walks away and
and look this is all about the cowboys
restricting his ability to become a free
agent let him go let him let's see what
the market bears no one seems to know
what the market would bear for dak
prescott well let him go to the market
and let's see
and that may happen in 2022. uh i i am
impressed by the fact
that dak
has never given in no that he's had
tremendous pressure placed upon him by
that cowboys franchise to take the deal
take the deal take the deal take the
deal and he's always said no and that is
not easy to do but he's made the right
business decision and now he's in great
shape 31-4 this year 37-6-8 next year
and then maybe free agency in 2022. yeah
maybe i i do give him a lot of credit
like you've said he has you know stood
strong throughout this
and hey from people i know i think
that's what's kind of struck the cowboys
just uh from a few people i've talked to
about this throughout the spring i think
ultimately the cowboys were always in
the thought process that dak would do
the team a solid and take a little bit
of a team-friendly you know little edge
off of what he was asking for and be
that guy because he has been everything
else has said through his career he's a
team guy and i think dallas knows that
so i think they're a little shocked that
he
you know was this
this hard line about the subject um but
but like to me
this is shaping up to
be even more expensive for the dallas
cowboys just that would be my just if
we're sitting here early before the 2020
season i would go
this looks like it could be joe flacco
but worse for the dallas cowboys because
again they're talented they're going to
be angry about you know the way last
year ended they got a new coach in there
who i think is going to light the you
know light a fuse on the whole bunch
he's going to be worth a few wins you
know and i think dallas is really
flirting with danger of i mean the brass
the the jones family of this team being
like 11 and 5 and him being one of the
two or three highest rated quarterbacks
in football and you know he throws for 4
800 yards and leads you know one of the
top two
or three people in touchdown passes then
it's going to be like whoa
yeah 37 million is a year is might what
it takes for a long long time or they're
gonna have to find some other way to be
creative with that contract
and you know to the extent that dak
prescott isn't taking into account
the necessity to pay other players i i i
think that he brings a unique mindset to
the table here
he was a fourth-round draft pick who
made peanuts yeah for four seasons
relative to his performance he knows
that the cba is set up in a way that it
creates opportunities every year for the
team to go out and add via the draft a
bunch of cheap players and if you draft
well and if you develop those players
you don't need to go pay superstars
right you you only pay some and you pay
me i'm your quarterback you take care of
the quarterback and if you have other
roster spots you go out and you draft a
guy in the fourth and they've been
drafted great so he can always say that
look you guys are doing great keep it
going yeah yeah you're right he's the
best example of it he's the best example
of it you don't need to go out and sign
a big name free agent and pay a bunch of
money you just need to go out and
continue drafting the way you have and
also speaking of the draft you mentioned
their alternative next year would be if
they let the dac walk away they can
draft somebody what if there's no
college football oh sure that's are you
going to be comfortable taking a flyer
on a third or a fourth round guy who
didn't play at all in 2020 right no
you're not you're right and that game
for a first rounder who's the first
rounder i don't know
trevor lawrence i know the kid from uh
the kid from uh ohio state yeah justin
fields that's right i mean those are the
only two guys right now i know people
are trying to say there's a kid up in
north dakota state who uh i can't say
you know people trying to put them in
that conversation but you're right it's
scary we don't know the prospects of
college football i think they're a lot
more dire than they are in the nfl and
you know
i don't know if i'm trevor lawrence and
they start telling me we're going to
start college football season in
february i'd be like yeah yeah i'll see
you no thank you i'm going to the nfl
draft i'll we'll go take it to the
supreme court whatever you want to do no
no he's going to the draft no he doesn't
need to sue anybody he's eligible for
the draft next april if they move
football to the spring the top prospects
will bail they will they're concerned
that they may they may bail now right
they may say screw this will the nfl
take away the rule of having to play
three years in college football are they
going to like don't have to you don't
have to play three years you just have
to be three years removed from
graduating high school that's right you
don't have to actually play right yeah
so if lawrence can say i'm i'm i'm he
can say i'm out right now i'm sitting
out the whole season uh i'm just gonna
go straight to the draft and there is
some thought the athletic had an item
last week about this that guys may
decide to do just that all right college
football is trying to get their their uh
handle on what's going to happen with
the pandemic the nfl is trying to get a
handle on it one of the things that
looks to be in grave danger is fans at
games
mark davis owner of the raiders told vic
tafer of the athletic over the weekend
that if
fans can't be at the games
he's not going to the games and if
some of the fans can't be at the games
none of the fans are going to be at the
games and then he won't be at the games
he wants a full stadium or nothing at
all i i think that this is just
mark davis channeling his dad al and
just being kind of a pain in the ass for
the league being kind of a renegade
right because he doesn't like what
they're doing and and the fans will be
very happy to hear him say he's not
going to go to the games and he wants
all of his fans there he doesn't want to
have to pick and choose they sold out
all the seats they've sold the psl's he
doesn't want to have to draw lines as to
who gets to come to games and who
doesn't so if nobody if if everybody
can't go then nobody goes including him
well i mean hey that's it sounds nice i
mean okay i don't really care whether
you're there or not you know mark i i
don't know what else to say there uh
yeah but i think you're right he's he's
kind of pandering to his his fan base of
the raiders and acting like he's part of
it which is cool and he i you know i i
believe he is part of it he's part of
that culture as much as anybody is in
this country so certainly he understands
what it's like to be a raider he grew up
as a damn raider uh and certainly still
has great influence there but you know i
think here you know the other thing that
kind of bothers me a little bit is cause
like i know in part of the comment or
quote that that mark davis talked about
he just said he wasn't happy with where
the nfl is
you know and that's to me where i would
just push back a little bit on mark
davis and be like hey mark you know yes
i'd like the nfl to have a few questions
answered too but i'd like our federal
government to have a whole lot more
questions answered and that's the
biggest problem in this issue still it's
not the nfl i'm sorry everybody it is
our federal government we have certain
states that don't want to you know
believe this is real and hey
everything's not going to turn around in
our country until we start to lower the
numbers and give people confidence to go
out and know that they're going to be
healthy again and until the federal
government starts to step in or up their
game a little bit right now because
they're like a minor league football our
baseball team right now to me
then nobody's gonna have the confidence
there's mixed messages nobody
understands what's going on we have a
leader that told us this was it got
blown and we blew it to dust it's dust
in the wind you know so no none of
that's real it's very much surging
better more than ever we're breaking
like breaking
uh
records daily so uh that's where i just
get a little passionate about that and
that just bothered me a little that he
went that way with that comment
one thing mark davis is passionate about
is the idea that the nfl was so hung up
on equity in the off season that if if
no coaches can be at facilities or if
one coach can't be at a facility then no
coaches can be there it's got to be the
same rules for everybody when it comes
to seating
uh
for fans the attitude is
who who whoever is allowed to have fans
you can have fans and you may have some
teams that have no home field advantage
you have other teams that may have a a
half full stadium or in theory you can
have an area where the pandemic's under
control and everybody could be there
davis said everything else has been
about equity this season then when you
get into attendance at the stadium all
of a sudden it's the wild west you all
make your own decisions don't look at us
it's not up to us it's like whoa and
look i think this is very simple they
want to save as much money as they can
so when it comes to the ability of fans
to attend the games
if you're in a situation where the city
and state government will allow you to
have fans then have fans and make back
some of that money that otherwise going
to lose and you can't take the position
i think it's stupid to take the position
that if there's just one team that that
can't have any fans then all teams
should have no fans that's ludicrous if
you can have fans based upon where your
team is and how your local government is
handling the pandemic then do it chris i
don't i don't have no problem with that
at all yeah i think they have a duty to
make as much money as they can and hey
if it creates an inequity if one stadium
is louder than the other well so be it
just deal with it because uh it's stupid
to not take advantage of the opportunity
to sell tickets and everything else that
generates revenue on game day agreed
agreed with that you're right i've got
nothing wrong with any of that but again
i think it still goes back to the point
i just made that the federal
government's got to clean up their act a
little bit and make everybody feel
comfortable to go starting in that
direction you know right now we only
have you know one part of the country
that's kind of heading in the right way
and that's the northeast and i think
that's because we were
hit so hard by it at first it scared the
death out of everybody up here and
everybody's still really
you know standing the protocol i can't i
don't go into a store any store anything
anywhere where nobody like everybody is
wearing masks up here and i don't see
large gatherings and you know hey the
the governor new york cuomo he did a
great job of he saw people too close
together in new york city when
restaurants got open and things like
that he put the kibosh on that right
away so you know i just think more
states and governors and of course our
federal government we need to get a
better handle on this whole thing and
then we could start talking about you
know fans in the stadium and everything
like that but
there's too much fear out there right
now because there's too much false
information and bull crap and misleading
statements uh that have confused people
well and look i we could go on and on
about it and uh we probably will
i it's a mess and it's inexcusable
and uh
it's astounding when you consider
what we're hearing from our elected
leaders
and the behavior that we're witnessing
from our fellow americans who still
don't understand the way they should the
behavior that is required
to limit the spread of the virus and who
still
view this as a risk similar to jumping
out of an airplane
riding a motorcycle
going rock climbing
those things entail a risk to you yeah
this thing entails a risk to you
and everyone you come into contact with
everyone you live with everyone you work
with everyone you see on a regular basis
and if you get the virus
uh
you may give it to someone else and it
may kill them and the fact that there's
no fingerprints that will show that it
was you
doesn't make it okay it doesn't make it
right it doesn't even begin to make it
something that
that a normal functioning brain should
even be able to process and yet here we
are chris i look and and it's why is any
of this political i don't get it
why is it not only about what is right
for the country what is right for the
people what is right for the kids
let the science drive it not ignore the
science it's it's like
the the past four months to me
have been an extended episode of the
twilight zone and i'm just waiting to
the point where we find out that it's
all a cookbook hey it's it's all well
you know i don't you're gonna get me
pissed off here and i'm gonna get worse
and worse as we get into this
conversation so we should probably end
but there's only one group of people in
the world right now that really aren't
bought into this
and you know i'm not gonna sit here and
try to get political on everybody but we
know who that group is all right and i'm
sorry
i'm sorry that group if you don't like
it right now and you're mad at me i
don't know what else to say sorry but
that's just the truth here's the point
here's the point
uh
the toronto blue jays can't play home
games this year yeah because
the canadian government doesn't want
americans yeah they don't trust the
virus did you trust us and and they
don't want the toronto blue jays going
to america and bringing the virus back
america's the crazy drunk uncle right
now that's who we are we're the crazy
junk drunk uncle just
one virus
we're idiots right now that's all i
could say i'm putting myself in that i'm
american but we're idiots as a country
right now well
on that note i'm going to say goodbye to
the crazy high uncle uh
but we'll be we'll look and that's why
why people
we need to take care of each other we
need to do the right thing and we need
to give a crap about this virus ignoring
it is not going to make it go no way i
think that's been fairly well
established that's it hopefully you
won't ignore us join us on tuesday
morning for pft live peter king is going
to join us to talk about what he learned
during his visit to minnesota and their
preparations for football in a pandemic
all day long check us out at
profootballtalk.com have a great monday
we'll see you tomorrow see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports